[MUSIC PLAYING]
JELYNN MALONE: I
am Jelynn Malone.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG:
I'm Bev Magtanong.
SPEAKER: Oh, wait.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG:
Oh, is this not on?
Hi.
I'm Bev Magtanong.
MIKE ARQUINES: Hi.
I'm Mike Arquines.
SAM MAGTANONG: Hi.
I'm Sam Magtanong.
JELYNN MALONE: All right.
Well, welcome.
Thank you guys so much for
spending your afternoon
with us.
We are Mostra Coffee.
And I wanted to first
off say, thank you to you
guys for having us.
Moses, thank you for
coming into Mostra
and bringing us out here.
We're so honored to
be a part of Google.
You guys are Google.
I mean, there's nothing
cooler than Google, right?
But yeah, so I just want to
introduce my partners again.
So Bev Magtanong.
She and I started the
company, brought on Mike,
and then brought on Sam.
So we've had such a crazy
journey up to this point.
We are actually celebrating
our fifth year in business
this year.
And it's been an eventful year.
We opened two retail
locations this year,
which is a lot for anybody.
So we opened up two
retail locations.
We've done a number of
beer collaborations.
Mike, how many beer
collaborations would
you say we've done
up to this point?
MIKE ARQUINES:
We're at about 420
in the last maybe
four years actually.
JELYNN MALONE: OK.
Yeah.
SAM MAGTANONG: So pretty close.
JELYNN MALONE: And then so
our biggest collaboration
is with Stone Brewing Company.
Everyone knows Stone
Brewing Company, right?
So one of their
most popular beers
is the Xocoveza Mocha Stout.
And we collaborated with them.
And we do that every
year with them.
And it's nationally distributed.
And it's probably
our biggest account.
But we've done that.
And one of the biggest,
most blowing ones
is that this year we were named
one of the top three finalists
for Micro Roaster
of the Year 2019.
And that was quite
humbling for us.
And now we're at Google.
So I mean, this is definitely
on the list of the cool things
that we've had an
opportunity to do.
I wanted to go over
just kind of the things
we're going to be
talking about today.
We're going to be
talking about coffee.
We're going to be talking
about specialty coffee,
and what that is, coffee
roasting, the innovation
of coffee, and how
that is involved
with craft beer, and food
and many other things,
as well as community.
It's kind of a weird
situation how we all got here.
My partners and I were doing
things so far from coffee.
I have a background
in entertainment
as a TV host and a
film and TV actress.
Nothing to do with coffee.
Bev is a graduate of
the Boston Conservatory
and a professional opera singer,
and owns her own vocal studio.
And so if you need
voice lessons, call Bev.
And then there's Mike, which he
still is Chef Mike in my phone.
He's a fine dining chef,
and owns his own company
called the Lab Dining Sessions.
And Sam is a veteran.
Actually, he's a
captain in the army.
He was a captain in the
army, fought in Iraq.
Happy Veterans Day, Sam.
And he has transitioned
into becoming a health care
executive.
So how we all ended
up doing coffee
is probably the most
interesting thing.
And it's probably the most
synchronicity part of it, too.
Bev and I have been
friends, best friends,
for over 20 years.
We went to middle school
and high school together.
And in high school, we were
dreaming up these businesses
that we could own together.
And then after high school,
we left San Diego, pursued
careers in entertainment,
and college, and all that,
and about 10 years after that,
we came back to San Diego.
And when we came
back, we started
working with a
charity organization
to help aid the poor
in the Philippines.
And we got the opportunity to
travel out to the Philippines.
We fell in love with the
culture, which our families are
all from the Philippines.
But we got to go there as adults
and experience the Philippines.
And we recognized not
only the beautiful people
and the culture, but also
the gravity of the poverty
out there.
And we learned that the only
way that you could really
help eradicate
poverty is to provide
job opportunities instead of
just like giving them money.
So anyway, we came home,
and we were like, OK,
that was extremely inspiring.
How are we going to
eradicate poverty?
We don't know.
But that was that.
So a few years later, she and
I started a pastry company.
We don't bake at all.
But we hired a pastry chef.
And we started a pastry company.
And Sam, being an executive
in the health care industry,
he had a facility
that needed a cafe.
So he gave us the opportunity
to open up a cafe.
So we went to go do that.
But if you're going to have
pastries, you need coffee.
But we didn't drink
coffee at all.
We were like the Starbucks
drinker girls that are like,
let's get the most sugar
with extra whipped cream,
and we don't want to
taste any coffee at all.
But we needed
coffee for our shop.
So the only person
we knew really
that drank coffee was Mike.
And we had met Mike when we
were doing all of our charity
events, because he was like
a chef at one of the events.
So I was like stalking
him on social media.
And he always posted
stuff about coffee.
So I called him,
and I'm like, hey,
could you show us
around and maybe
introduce us to some
coffee roasters in town?
He did that.
Bev and I not being
coffee drinkers
were not that into this.
But we got there, and we
tried specialty coffee
for the first time.
And it was a
mind-blowing experience.
The wide range of
flavors and the kinds
of products that come
from specialty coffee
were so interesting.
So we left that
trip and came home.
And this light bulb
basically went off.
And we realized-- we
were like, wait a minute.
Let's not do the pastry company.
Let's be coffee roasters.
We don't know
think about coffee,
but we're going to
do that instead.
So we started Mostra Coffee.
And we called Mike to see if
he could help us learn more
about coffee.
And he so happened
to have always
had a dream to roast coffee.
We're like, great, you
could be our roaster.
But none of us, again,
knew what we were doing.
So we just were winging it.
We were totally winging it.
So we started roasting.
We bought a roaster.
And we started roasting out of
Bev and Sam's garage in Forest
Ranch.
Sorry to all the neighbors
in Forest Ranch that
were smelling all the coffee,
because it actually doesn't
smell like brewed coffee.
Roasted coffee
smells like popcorn.
And anyway, it's not the same.
So anyway, we started
roasting coffee.
And the company actually
started to grow.
We started closing
wholesale accounts.
We were closing accounts with
Tender Greens and companies
like that.
And breweries started
calling us for coffee.
And so then we ended up
bringing on another partner.
And then Sam to bring more
of a corporate structure
and their expertise to
actually growing this business,
because again, Hollywood, opera
singer, chef, we're like, OK,
here we are.
So fast forward.
Here we are five
years later with being
named one of the top three micro
roasters in the United States.
I still don't know
how that has happened.
But we're so extremely
humbled and grateful.
And why we decided
coffee and not coconut--
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Or bamboo.
JELYNN MALONE: Or bamboo,
which were other things that
are grown in the Philippines.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Right.
So I mean, we could have
done different things.
Bamboo, coconut,
these are other things
that are really abundant
in the Philippines,
but we chose coffee.
And we chose specialty coffee.
And why specialty coffee, right?
So terms like specialty
coffee or craft coffee
are terms that more
and more people
are starting to use these days.
And I mean, it makes sense,
because specialty coffee
is growing.
It's grown by about 2% every
single year for the last 16
years or so to the point
where Starbucks has actually
created their own line
of reserve coffees
and their own chain of
reserve coffee shops.
So if you haven't been inside
a Starbucks Reserve coffee
shop, what you'll find in
there are various bags, really
nice bags, of single origin
coffees, fancy espresso
machines, manual
pour over methods.
And it's really
Starbucks's way of creating
a space for the specialty
coffee consumer.
So this is happening.
And people are like,
OK, what's going on?
Why specialty coffee?
What is specialty coffee, right?
How does specialty coffee
differ from regular coffee?
And most importantly
to some people,
why is my cup of
specialty coffee
more expensive than
the cup of coffee
that I can get at
like the gas station?
So every single day
here in the States,
400 million cups of
coffee are consumed.
About 59% of those
coffee cups are
brewed with specialty coffee.
So that's 236 million
cups of coffee
that are brewed with
specialty coffee.
How many people are actually
looking inside their cup
and thinking I know how that
coffee got inside my cup
or even questioning how
it got into their cup?
Jelynn mentioned that I
am a classical singer.
I was trained as a classical
singer since I was 12.
And people always ask me, how
do you go from classical singing
to coffee?
It's random, and it's completely
different, which it totally is.
They're two totally
different industries.
Yet at the same time,
they're so similar,
in that the complexities
and the nuances and the work
and the detail that goes into
becoming a classical musician,
like learning vocal
technique, and the time
that it takes to
learn vocal technique,
or learning foreign languages,
and observing foreign languages
in conjunction with
a composer's work,
those kind of
complexities and details
I was able to find so
similarly in specialty coffee.
And I'm going to tell you
how they're so similar,
and how those kinds of details
are present in this industry.
Mike is going to
do that, too, as he
gets into his roasting portion.
But the coffee bean
starts at the farm.
It starts in a farm outside
of the states in countries
like Costa Rica, or Guatemala,
or Brazil, or Indonesia,
or Papua New Guinea.
And the arabica
coffee bean, which
is the type of coffee that
can be considered a specialty
coffee, is grown in the highland
mountains of these countries.
So it's grown at about 3,000
to 6,500 feet in elevation.
And these farms are tilled,
and they're maintained
by sometimes single families.
They don't have access to
advanced farming equipment
or technology.
And their way of farming
is really by sight or feel
or partnering with outside
coffee partners that
come into the mountains.
And they help them
make sure that they're
adhering to best farming
practices and processes.
Now, these arabica coffee
trees take a long time to grow.
They take about
three to five years
to get to maturity to be able
to harvest coffee from them,
as opposed to some of
these other coffees,
like robusta or liberica.
So those types of
coffees are actually
grown in the lowlands
of the mountains.
They grow aggressively.
You can grow a lot of it,
and you can grow it often.
So these are coffees
that you will
find in your instant coffee.
They don't have as delicate
a flavor as arabica coffee.
They're bitter,
and they're harsh.
And they're considered
commercial coffee.
So like I said, arabica coffee
takes a long time to grow.
They are really
susceptible to disease.
Just because they're
in the highlands,
so there's a lot of rains.
There's a lot of moisture.
So mold ends up
becoming an issue.
So these trees really
take careful cultivating.
The trees produce a cherry.
So a lot of people don't
know that coffee actually
starts inside a cherry.
Those trees bear fruit.
And one arabica coffee
tree makes enough cherries
for 1 to 2 pounds
of roasted coffee.
So let's put that
in perspective.
It takes 2,000
cherries to produce
1 pound of roasted coffee.
That means that the
average two cup a day
coffee drinker annually is
going to have consumed 18 trees.
It's a lot of cherries.
And remember, these cherries
aren't picked by some machine.
They're hand-picked
by these farmers.
They're going out
into the field,
and they're hand
picking these cherries.
Now, once they actually
pick the cherries,
it has to go through
a whole process.
Mike is going to go into more
detail about these processes.
But they have to actually
sort out ripe cherries
from unripe cherries.
So sometimes this
is done by hand.
Sometimes they actually
put them in water.
And the cherries that
are floating are unripe,
and the ones that
are sinking are ripe.
So that's how they can
tell the difference.
From there I can go through
a deep pulping method.
So they'll take the bean
actually outside of the cherry.
Then it gets fermented.
Then it gets dried.
And it has to dry
so that the moisture
content inside the bean actually
gets to a certain percentage.
And then it gets milled.
And then it gets bagged.
And then it comes
down the mountain
by a horse or a
donkey, because there's
no helicopter that's
going up there and getting
these coffees.
And then it's exported.
But before it gets
exported, we've
got third party
green coffee buyers
that actually come on site.
These people are
typically queue graders.
So queue graders are
the official people that
can actually grade this coffee.
They've gone through
a lot of training.
They've tasted a lot of coffee,
and actually are certified
people that come and taste
and grade these coffees.
So they'll take a green
sample of the raw coffee.
And they'll look at it.
And they're able to identify
what kind of defects
the coffee may have.
Now, defects could be
discoloration of the coffee.
It could be insect damage.
It could be broken or
chipped coffee beans.
And if there are enough
defects in that sample,
that coffee may not even
move onto the next level,
which is the roasting.
So once the coffee gets moved
on, if it does get moved on,
they'll roast that
sample of coffee,
and then they'll actually
cup it, or they'll taste it.
And what they're looking for
is sweetness in the coffee.
They're looking for how
clean the coffee tastes,
meaning how many off flavors
are present or not present
inside the coffee.
They're looking for any defects.
And they'll grade
it, essentially.
And so if it gets graded
as an 80 or higher--
the specialty coffee grade
scale is out of 100--
if it gets graded
an 80 or higher,
then it's considered specialty.
If it's below that, it's not.
So if it's specialty, they'll
consider it in their inventory
to push out to the roasters.
Another situation that happens
is that roasters actually
go to the farm themselves.
Now, this is a great
situation, because it's
called direct trade.
So the farmers will go and
sell directly to the roasters.
And the roasters will
do the same thing.
They'll cup the coffee.
They'll decide if they
want to bring it in.
And then what's great is that
the farmer gets typically
more money per pound of
coffee, because you get rid
of the middleman
in that situation.
And you're working
directly with the farmer.
So once the
roasters, once we get
that coffee, what
we have to do is
we actually have to roast that
coffee at different levels.
And then we have to
cup it, and taste
all of those different levels
of coffee, roasted coffee.
And then to decide
which coffee we want
to push out into the market.
Once that happens, it gets
brought to the baristas.
And then the baristas have
to actually figure out
what coffee to
water ratio is going
to make the best cup of coffee
and be the best representation
of that origin or that blend.
And then it gets brewed.
And it gets sold
to the consumer.
So as you can see, the journey
from seed at the farm to cup
is a crazy one.
And there's a lot of hands that
are involved in that process,
and a lot of people that have
to uphold a certain quality
and standard throughout
that whole process.
So the next time that you
see a latte for $4 or $4.50,
and you might be wondering
why it costs that much,
you'll know that that's
why, because the process is
so laborious.
At Mostra, we take
pride in being
really innovative and
creative with our coffees.
I think it's one of the things
that really sets us apart
from other roasters.
And Mike here is a
great asset to us,
because he's actually
a fine dining chef,
like Lynn mentioned.
He actually graduated
from the Art Institute
here in San Diego.
And he has worked in really
prestigious restaurants,
like Charlie Trotter's in
Chicago and Le Bernardin
in New York.
And he is really able
to approach the coffee
with a culinary mindset.
And it's really
been so fun to be
able to see him
work with the coffee
and be able to do
amazing things with it.
So Mike is going
to take it away.
MIKE ARQUINES: Thank you.
Thank you.
How's everybody doing today?
AUDIENCE: Good!
MIKE ARQUINES: Fantastic.
A little brief, quick
blurb about myself.
I was supposed to be a nurse.
I'm Filipino.
I'm either in the
military or I'm a nurse.
My mother, so pretty much,
I broke my mom's heart
at the end of the day.
She's a nurse, amazing nurse.
She worked long hours in
Oakland emergency room,
night shift, yay high.
They called her little Napoleon.
She ruled with an iron fist.
And she is my inspiration.
But I did break her heart.
I decided to pursue a career
in the culinary field.
And to her it was not
the ideal situation,
because for her coming
from the Philippines,
it was all about
stability, and money,
and being able to
provide for your family.
And she felt that at the time
that route just wasn't ideal.
So I broke her heart.
Nurse.
Educated myself.
Culinary arts management
at San Diego Art Institute.
I traveled to New York, did
a stint at Le Bernardin,
came back, worked in
and around San Diego,
went to Charlie Trotter's
Chicago for a while,
at which I spent
most of my time.
A very intense kitchen.
If you could
imagine kind of like
Gordon Ramsay like times five.
It was insane.
So anyways, I came back
here, and here we are.
Lab Dining Sessions
stands for collaboration.
I opened that in 2009.
And we provide unique
dinner experiences,
multi-course experiences that
I felt that was happening,
and was hot in New
York and in Chicago.
And to bring that
here was definitely
something new for San Diego.
So yeah.
So we started in a garage.
We're "garagepreneurs," pretty
much, I would like to say.
Almost burnt the house
down, as everyone asked.
I mean, we sprung
for this roaster.
And so I'm a flavor nerd.
I love flavor.
I love the process of
manipulation of flavors
and taste, and just techniques.
So as I'm just--
we pretty much just
googled a lot of things.
Yeah.
We googled techniques
and forums.
And that's pretty
much how I learn.
I ask a lot of questions,
take a lot of good notes.
And then at the end of the
day, what does it taste like?
You could go through so
many different variations
of variables throughout
the roasting process.
But at the end of the
day, does it taste good?
So that's what we relied
on a lot in the beginning
and up to this point
is, does it taste good?
So why innovation?
Because why not?
Coffee is a part of daily life
for all of us, or most of us,
I would say.
And it was for me
working in the kitchen,
or whether you're a
nurse, or you're a doctor,
or you're in the military, or
you're working in an office,
or you're working at
Google, it doesn't matter.
Coffee definitely gets
you through the day.
But we wanted to provide
it in such a way that
made it exciting, not
just providing you
with a good cup of coffee,
but also the experience
to that cup of coffee.
And that's why we
at Mostra focus on
not only the sourcing
and the responsibility
and the community, but also
the experience, customer
experience, for a
premium product.
And that's a new and exciting.
So I always like
to think about when
I'm roasting coffee
and the approach
to coffee or the approach to
cold brews and other products,
it runs parallels to
the culinary world,
because its flavor first, right?
So for example, when we're
creating a blend of coffee,
it's just like--
in my mind, I'm
like, OK, so you're
taking three or four
different kinds of coffees,
and you're layering flavors
that each one provides, just
like stock.
You guys make stock at home.
Chicken stock, they call
it bone broth nowadays.
But that's like the buzz word.
But chicken stock, beef stock,
vegetable stock, fish stock.
It's all the same concept.
If you start with a great base,
and then you go into deglazing,
and you add another layer of
flavor that's your acidity,
and then you add
another, then you
add your broth,
which can be your--
or if you do glazing
with red wine,
you have your tannic qualities.
And then you have
the broth, which
is the richness and the body.
That sounds like a blend
to me, an espresso blend.
So again, that's how I draw
inspiration and parallels
to what I do or what
we do here at Mostra.
So my number one thing is
to always think as a kid
when I'm trying to
think of a product,
because kids are always curious.
They're always wondering
why, asking themselves why,
asking a lot of questions.
And I still do the
same thing to this day,
because that just
keeps me on my toes.
And again, keep it fresh.
Keep it awesome.
So community collaboration
is one big thing we do.
Some of the biggest things
we do here at Mostra
is we were known--
people know us as a
cold brew company.
They found us through cold brew.
At one point it was like,
whoa, like it's just cold brew,
right?
We felt like, why aren't
more people doing this?
It's 70% less acidic.
It's easier on the
stomach for people.
This was back like
five years ago.
And people were literally
buying bottles of cold brew
at their house, where
we would brew it.
And it was like, OK, we were
probably onto something.
Other roasters at the time
were kind of not on board.
They're like, no, that's
not what we're about.
Which is OK, but why not?
Why not?
And then in conjunction with
that, being in San Diego,
we have a big craft beer
presence, big craft beer
community.
We have some of the best
craft beers in the world.
I am a craft beer nerd as well.
And I derive a lot
of my inspiration
from those breweries as well.
They create a base stout
for a lot of beers.
And then from there,
they throw in,
whether it's hazelnuts
and marshmallows or coffee
or so on and so forth.
I was like, why don't we
try that with our cold brew?
So we started dabbling
with different ingredients
that we felt would complement
and contrast our coffee.
So our first one was our
One-Brazilian Coconuts,
which we use fresh coconut
and fresh vanilla bean.
And until this day, it's
one of our best sellers.
It literally tastes like an
Almond Joy or a Mounds bar.
It's fantastic.
But sourcing great
product, using it
with respect, and finesse,
and not messing it up,
and sourcing great coffee
that's the key to our products.
And then so with that, those are
how our collaborations really
started.
We started with one, and
then it turned to three,
and then it turned to
eight, and then turned-- now
we're at 400 plus right now.
Why?
Because we wanted to not
only build community through
our products and also work
with like-minded crafty people
and talented people, but
we wanted to provide--
we felt the need to provide a
service now to these breweries.
And how do we do that?
Breweries typically
would go to a store
or go to a fellow roaster and be
like, hey, I'm making a stout.
OK, cool, here you go.
I hope this tastes good.
Normally, that's what happens.
But in my head, I'm
like, OK, so if they
spend so much time in hop
selection in New Zealand
and they travel and they do
all this to make a beer, well,
if they're making
a coffee stout,
they probably want
to select the coffee
and work with the
right roaster properly
just as much as they
would attention to detail
in hops selection, for example.
So we felt there was that need.
So we like to say we like
to custom tailor the beers
like a suit.
The coffee like a
suit to this beer.
So now if they're brewing a
stout, we'll have a meeting.
I'll say, hey,
what's your process?
What's your mineral?
What's your water quality like?
What's your infusion?
Where are you infusing?
What side of the brew
side are you infusing?
Are going to barrel agent?
What's the finishing ABV?
Stuff like that.
Because all that
plays into flavor.
So when I have all
that information,
maybe after two meetings, then
we'll talk coffee after that.
So with all the success
with the breweries
and the collaborations,
and with all the products
that all these breweries were
pumping out with our name
on it, I was like, man, this
is definitely something that--
what else can we do with it?
Because why not, right?
A lot of our beers are barely
barrel-aged beers, big, hefty,
12%-plus beers.
And what do they
do with the beers
after they're
dumped and bottled?
They just have these
barrels that they turn
into furniture or for plants.
And what do you call those?
Pottery, whatever, anyways.
So I was like, why don't we
take those barrels and age
green coffee in it?
Because green coffee is
porous, meaning like an egg.
An egg is porous.
You put in the fridge.
You put it next to
something very pungent.
It'll absorb those flavors.
Now you make scrambled
eggs in the morning.
Now you have that flavored
scrambled eggs in the morning.
So we took green beans, aged
them in a barrel, for example.
It absorbs the flavors that
were in the barrel, big stout.
Plus it used to be
a bourbon barrel.
So 12 years, 10, 12 years of
bourbon whiskey from Kentucky.
All that push and pull in
the wood in the flavors.
It's like a time
machine of flavor.
And that gets absorbed
into the green coffee.
We roast it.
We check moisture content
on it constantly, agitating,
rotating, the barrel.
And then we'll sample roast.
Like Bev said, we sample roast
coffee to taste for defects
or flavor qualities we like or
we do not like, and we adjust,
take notes.
And then we have our
finished product.
Now, you're tying community.
Why?
Because you're taking two
brands that normally don't work
together in this way and
providing this product that's
exciting, where
when I say exciting,
people are lining up for it.
And these lines are insane.
Beer releases are insane.
Sometimes people camp out
for two days for a beer.
We've had people camp out
for coffee at like 1:00 AM.
It's pretty awesome.
And that's the
power of community,
and obviously marketing.
But if the product is
great, people will come.
So that's also a big part
of innovation, in my mind,
and in our mind.
So on top of the
400-plus beers that we've
done, on top of the
cold brews we've done,
the barrel aging,
all that, we like
to think that we are
great at bridging
gaps between different crafts.
And bridging these crafts
together is huge for us,
because now you're taking
people who normally either
don't drink coffee at that
level, or they do drink coffee.
And now, whether you're in a
kitchen or you're a distiller
or you're a brewer, we're
actually tying all these crafts
together with our products.
Yeah, so.
SAM MAGTANONG: That was
my cue, bridging gaps.
MIKE ARQUINES: Yes.
SAM MAGTANONG: It was my cue.
So my name is Sam.
And I get a chance to
tie it all together,
and to close this segment.
We didn't get a chance to really
highlight Jelynn's background.
So Jelynn is a working TV film
actor in Hollywood for TV shows
like "General Hospital,"
"Las Vegas" on NBC,
and a number of films.
She's hosted her own shows on
VH1, TV Guide Channel, Nike,
ABC's backstage host for
the Emmys, to name a few.
They brought the non-performer
on a team of performers
to Google Talks.
I'm also deathly afraid
of public speaking.
And I don't memorize
lines very well.
So I'm the only one
with a notebook.
And I wrote every single
word that I was going
to say in case I forget it.
Lynn was an actress in
Hollywood for a number of years.
Beverly was a classically
trained opera singer.
Mike is a fine dining chef.
I'm an immigrant.
I was born in the Philippines.
I came here when I
was four years old.
I'm also a veteran.
I felt it was my calling.
And it was an honor for
me to serve my country.
I'm also the grandson
of a rice former.
Farming culture and the
love for the land, I think,
is definitely in my blood.
My grandfather planted
rice for over 60 years
in the same plot of land
before he passed away
a couple of years ago.
When we went to the Philippines,
when I went to the Philippines
in 2015, and I spoke
to my grandfather
in the southern part of the
Philippines in Mindanao,
and I asked him, Lola, where
are the coffee farmers?
He pointed to the
mountains, and he
said, go climb up the
mountains, and go start speaking
to the coffee farmers.
And I did.
The Philippines is the perfect
setting for growing coffee.
It's got climate.
It's got elevation.
It's got the soil.
It's got the manpower.
It's got the farm, and
the farming culture.
Across the world in the coffee
belt, as Beverly mentioned,
Guatemala, the countries
in South America,
Papua New Guinea.
You've got other African
countries, like Ethiopia.
You've got Indonesia.
Coffee and growing coffee has
been the mechanism for wealth
generation for these
farmers, but unfortunately
in the Philippines,
due to the politics
and to the current
economic situation there,
the Filipino farmers
are impoverished.
There's not enough coffee
production in the Philippines
to meet local
consumption of coffee.
They're importing from
outside the country
over 50% of the
coffee consumption,
much less exporting to
other parts of the world
or bringing their specialty
coffee to you all here.
But the coffee bean still
provides the best promise
and the means for
inclusion to these farmers
and to the indigenous
peoples that
are growing these
coffees in the mountain
regions of southern
Mindanao, in northern Luzon
in the Philippines, that have
historically been excluded
from their communities.
So as a Filipino and American,
and as Filipino-Americans here,
the passion behind
our project has
been to elevate the plights
of the Philippine farmer
to honor our past
and our history,
to provide economic
opportunity, and to elevate
the Philippine bean to
the global world market.
When we applied for the Roaster
of the Year competition,
sponsored by "Roast"
magazine this past year,
our coffee submission was
the humble Philippine bean.
And as others submitted some
of the world's top coffees,
we were compelled to submit
that as part of our legacy
and as part of our story.
We have a barista
here who you'll
meet outside who's helping
us with the roasting
demonstration.
He'll be competing in the
preliminaries of the US Coffee
Championships in Denver
on December 1 and 2.
And his bean of choice is going
to be the Philippine bean.
As we continue to tell the
story of the bean in general
and the Philippine
bean in particular,
we hope to be able to honor our
past that allows us to explain
how I got here, how we all got
here, and allows us to wonder
what the future could bring.
So five years ago, we started
Mostra Coffee in my garage.
I turned to my wife.
Beverly is my better half.
And she said to me, we're going
to start a roasting company.
And we're going to pull all
of our money, our savings,
along with the savings
of all of our partners,
and we're going to start
a roasting company.
I turned to them.
You don't know
anything about coffee.
You don't know anything
about business.
And you're an opera singer.
How are we going
to make this work?
But that's what we did.
We started roasting in our
garage 1 pound of coffee
at a time.
We took all of our
money and savings,
and we bought a 1-pound
profile roaster,
and we named her,
affectionately, Francesca,
or Franny for short.
You'll meet her outside.
What inspired us then to go
for broke and to take a risk
is what continues to
fuel our vision today,
that through a
simple cup of coffee,
and the very powerful spirit
of community and collaboration,
that we can inspire
one another to be
the best versions of ourselves.
So Mostra in Italian
means to perform,
performance, exhibition, show.
And all the owners
really want to do
is just through their
own inspired performance
to be better people.
And through our own performance,
can we inspire others?
Can we inspire you to perform
to the best of your ability?
We can build and
connect and inspire
local and global communities
to create opportunities,
real opportunities, that impact
people's lives and families.
We can create impactful
and meaningful experiences
and connection that we, us
four, can be the reason,
and all of us out here listening
can be the reason that people
see the goodness in humanity.
As we observe Veterans Day
today and as we commemorate
the 100th anniversary
of the armistice that
went into effect on the
11th hour of the 11th day
of the 11th month
in the year 1918
that ended the war
to end all wars,
Mostra's vision is
even more clear to me.
As we are being reminded that
the old demons are rising
again, ready to complete
their task of chaos
and death that was spoken
by the French president
over the weekend's
commemorations
during Armistice Day, that the
old demons are rising again
ready to destroy and to
wreak havoc and chaos,
our mission is very, very clear.
It's through a simple
cup of coffee--
however you drink your
coffee, with cream, or sugar,
or simple black, or a nice cold
brew, or a shot of espresso,
or a fancy latte--
that we can come together, and
that we can find common ground,
and that there are more that
unites us than what divides us.
And the last sentence
of our mission statement
is a real symbol.
We are one.
That's all I have.
Thank you for inviting us.
MIKE ARQUINES: Thank
you, everybody.
SAM MAGTANONG: To speak.
And I know we have a few
more things for you in store.
JELYNN MALONE: I think we
have to open up for questions,
right?
Anyone have any questions?
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Anyone have
any questions for us today?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So just one.
I don't know very much
about coffee at all.
But one thing I do know
is about the roast cycle.
You can have different
types of roasts.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Right.
AUDIENCE: Do you typically take
a single batch of green beans
and say, we're going to
do a medium roast for this
or we're going to
dark roast for this?
Or do you kind of say, OK,
let's try the gamut here
with this particular
batch of green beans?
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: So Mike,
do you want to take this one?
MIKE ARQUINES: Am I on?
OK.
Yeah, so we try to source
as seasonal as possible.
And with that being
said, we get notes
on these coffees that we--
for example, if it's a Costa
Rica, before we bring it in,
we'll already know
what we're looking for,
and how we should
probably approach it
based on whether it's elevation
and how it's processed.
So that we're kind of ahead
of the game once it comes in.
And as we're building
this library of origins,
we could bring in
any type of African
and kind of roast it similar,
and then adjust at that time,
because it's going to vary
from crop to crop, regardless.
So we kind of have a
premeditated approach to it
before we get it, and
then, say, if it's
that Costa Rica, we feel that
at a medium roast spectrum,
we're going to be able to
bring out more of what we want
from it, the chocolate, the
cocoa, the molasses coming out
of it.
So that, to me, sounds
like a medium dark roast.
But then when you
go on the other end
of the spectrum, which is like
we bring in our Ethiopians,
which are, for
example, a wash process
versus a natural process.
You're talking wash, which is
more lemony and lively acidity.
And then you have a natural
process, which is fruity.
So just by knowing
those keywords,
we're like, OK, this is how we
should probably approach it.
AUDIENCE: For a given
batch, you'll typically
choose one approach for it.
Is that what you're saying?
MIKE ARQUINES: Well,
when we sample roast,
there's a predetermined--
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Range.
MIKE ARQUINES: Range
of steps that we
need to hit according to the
Specialty Coffee Association.
And then from there, we'll
taste it, and we're like, OK.
You'll learn like maybe
60% of what that coffee is.
And then the other 40%
if we really like it,
we'll bring in a bigger
batch, or a full bag of it.
And then we'll profile
roast it, meaning
we'll roast it at different
temperatures, drop
temps, charge temps,
and development times.
And then we'll cup it.
We'll rest it.
We'll cup it.
And at different-- through
the process of elimination,
we'll choose one or two cups.
And then from there, we'll
cup it blind, and do it.
And then that's how
we choose our coffee.
So it's a process.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: So not any--
we don't take an
origin of coffee
and say, OK, we're going to
do this as a medium roast.
We bring it in, and we'll
roast it at different levels.
And we'll cup it.
Nothing that we do at Mostra
is really dark at all, or even
really light, for that matter.
We kind of tend to stick
in that medium range.
We feel that most of the time
we can highlight a lot of what
that coffee has to bring.
So it's really
just a process of,
at the end of the
day, what tastes good?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
scale through one taster?
Assuming coffee is
grown naturally,
so different batches will have
different characteristics.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Correct.
AUDIENCE: How do you
make sure that you
get the same [INAUDIBLE]
at the end of it?
MIKE ARQUINES: I think
knowing your source is
the most important
thing and having
that relationship
with the farm, knowing
that their processes
are locked in.
And then you know what you're
getting year in, year out.
I mean, mother nature
dictates a lot of that, too,
because one coffee
that's grown on one
side of the mountain that had
more rain than the other one
on the other side is definitely
going to taste a lot different.
It's our job as roasters to
not only vet out those farmers
and then create
that relationship,
and then trusting our farmers.
And then from there,
they send us the coffee.
And we don't mess it up.
So we just try
not to mess it up.
If you source good
coffee, the key
is, what I've learned throughout
the years, is to just source
good coffee.
Don't mess it up.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: Do you
get consistently--
the bean is consistent enough
from a particular farmer
or a particular region?
MIKE ARQUINES: Yeah,
for the most part.
For the most part.
Yeah, I mean, you'll get
these really crazy micro lots
that you probably have
never seen or tasted.
But at the end of the day,
some of the coffees we source,
we have a relationship and we
can know what we're getting.
This is going to
constantly taste like this.
But again, that's why
quality control is paramount.
We're tasting every day.
We're cupping every day.
Even the stuff that
we're always pouring,
we'll take random samples of
roasts from the previous day
and just cup it just to
ensure that our customers are
getting a similar and
consistent experience.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: And I
think that a lot of that,
too, is education.
So a lot of consumers don't
realize that coffee is a crop.
And that it's going to change
as you get new crops in.
So a lot of that on
our part is being
able to educate the consumer,
like, hey, it is a crop.
We have a new lot
of Costa Rica in.
You'll find that maybe this
lot is a little bit more sweet
compared to the last lot.
Do you know what I mean?
And it's not good or bad.
It's just a different
crop of coffee.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you talk about
the different properties
of coffee, like flavor,
fruitiness, bitter, sweet,
is there some measurement
that you guys do?
Or is it just based
on tasting it?
I decided this is
sweet, so I label it.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: There is.
I mean, a Q Grader is actually--
there's a grading--
what is it called?
MIKE ARQUINES: It's
a tasting sheet.
It's like a-- yeah, like scales
of acidity and a bitterness.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG:
Sweetness, bitterness, body.
MIKE ARQUINES: Body.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: And so if
you're actually a Q Grader,
you're tasting these coffees,
and you're able to grade them.
And if you get a bunch
of Q Graders together,
those people should be able
to taste that one coffee
and be able to grade them
pretty similarly to each other.
For us on our roaster
level, for us, it's just,
does it taste sweet to us?
Do you know what I mean?
Does it taste good?
We're not necessarily going
into that detail of grading.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you all host
like coffee tasting events?
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: We do.
We do.
When we first started, we
were doing coffee cuppings--
JELYNN MALONE: Every weekend.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Every weekend
at Abnormal Wine Company,
which is now the Cork and Craft
and Abnormal Beer Company.
But we used to do
coffee cuppings
every week there as a way
to just get our name out
into the community, because
we were still operating out
of the garage.
And so now we will
do coffee cuppings.
If you were to email
us and say, hey, I've
got a group of
eight people, then
we could definitely accommodate
that and find a time.
So if you guys ever want
to do that here at Google
and come up to Mostra and
have a coffee cupping,
we would be more than happy
to host that for you guys.
AUDIENCE: I see a lot of
similar things in the language
that you are using with wine.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Have you
ever considered
aging as a way to prove or
change the nature of the coffee
tasting?
MIKE ARQUINES: Sam.
I'm just kidding.
He's like, yes.
Absolutely.
Wine is a great example.
But what's that
fact that you could
taste that there's more
flavors, detectable flavors?
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Yeah, there's
like over 1,000 more flavor
profiles to coffee than
there is wine, which
is really surprising to people.
MIKE ARQUINES: Yeah, very, very.
Yeah, we've aged wine--
or I'm sorry.
We've aged-- whoa, no.
We've aged coffee in wine
barrels, reds, whites, mead,
which is a honey wine.
We actually won
"Draft" magazine top
25 liquids of, I think, it was
2016, and with our good friends
at Superstition Meadery
in Prescott, Arizona.
So to be a coffee company
and to be able to have that
is pretty cool.
But yeah, I agree.
I think we're kind
of experimenting.
We have an urban winery right
next to us called Koi Zen.
And we saw them one day.
And they pressed their
own grapes in house.
And then they have the skins.
And I'm looking at it.
I'm like, man, they
look like raisins.
They kind of look like cascara,
the skins from coffee cherries.
So we're going to take
those and kind of experiment
with rehydrating
those into our coffee,
and then trying to brew
a cold brew maybe out
of that, or maybe semi
heat extraction with it,
and try to take it.
Not trying to get the
volatiles out from the skins,
like the bitterness and
those acrid flavors.
But yeah, definitely.
I mean, we take a
lot of inspiration
from wine, not just
spirits and beer.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
follow onto that.
People appreciate wine.
They're willing to
drop 30 or 300 or more
on a a bottle of wine.
MIKE ARQUINES: Right.
AUDIENCE: Has your
experience been
that here, at least
in the US market,
maybe internationally
as well, people are
becoming more sophisticated?
They understand that a
pourover of a small batch
is going to cost more than your
example earlier of gas station
coffee.
MIKE ARQUINES: I have this weird
infatuation with like diner
and gas station coffee.
I'm just letting you know.
I'm not saying it
tastes amazing.
I'm just saying like I'm
not knocking it at all.
But anyways, so I think
it's just what Bev said.
I think it's educating
the public, and awareness
for these products, and the type
of micro lots that are offered.
So why are you charging
$15 for a Panama Geisha?
Well, let me tell you why.
This is why.
So again, awareness, education,
and that in turn turns into--
it's great for us, because
now it is an easier sell.
I'm not saying there's going
to be $8 cups of coffee.
Maybe.
I mean, maybe.
But yeah, I mean--
JELYNN MALONE: Well, I was going
to say something that we do.
So if you go to our shop,
education and experience
is a huge thing that we do.
So our bar, so usually when
you go to a coffee bar,
the baristas are hiding
behind the big espresso
machines in the bar.
And you don't really
see what's going on.
But at Mostra, we
intentionally designed our bars
to be really low.
Everything's low and open,
so you see the entire thing.
We're actually-- I think
we're still the only coffee
shop in San Diego that has the
Mavam Espresso Machine, which
is a bar top espresso machine.
There's no big machine
in front of you.
So everything's below.
So you get to see
the whole process.
And I think part of
that is our attempt
to continue to educate the
consumer as to why they're
paying so much money, what
the process really is,
and all the details
that we as baristas,
and coffee companies,
and us at Mostra
really put into every
single cup of coffee.
So I think that's helping
it gain its value as well.
MIKE ARQUINES: Absolutely.
JELYNN MALONE: Any
other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Since you're coming
from unrelated backgrounds,
I have an unrelated question.
Could you improvise
and sing something?
MIKE ARQUINES: Thank you.
Thank you.
JELYNN MALONE: Oh, my gosh,
I almost put her on the spot.
SAM MAGTANONG: So I
fell in love with her
as a 16-year-old in the
choir in high school.
And it was her voice that
made me fall in love.
And when I went to Iraq in
'06 and '07 and I came back
a little hurt from the
experience, it was music,
and it was her music
that restored my soul.
So I would absolutely
love it if you
can sing a few bars in
front of this audience
and in front of a live audience.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: I'll
give you a line, OK?
A line.
[SINGING OPERA]
And that's it.
That's what everyone's getting.
It's true.
I am a classical singer.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I liked that.
Well, first of all,
congratulations.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: We loved
hearing your story.
Thank you for like adding
your personal touches.
And I was going to ask about
Mostra Coffee as a brand
and what it meant to you
guys, but you mentioned
where the name came about.
I'd love to hear what's
next for you guys.
You guys have opened two shops.
What do you guys see in the
next couple of years at Mostra
in San Diego or beyond?
JELYNN MALONE: OK.
Where do I begin?
Uh, no.
Definitely expanding
into more locations.
It's so crazy, because
we're in Carmel Mountain
Ranch in San Diego.
So that's like north,
inland San Diego.
And people drive from LA,
Orange County, Riverside County,
East Lake, I mean,
all over San Diego
to come to our shop in little
old Carmel Mountain Ranch.
And it's crazy, because
we, the three of us,
Sam, Bev, and I, all went to
Ranch Bernardo High School.
So anyway, it's a trip.
So we want to become more
accessible to the community
and open up more
locations around town.
So by next year, next
year, we should have--
my husband's back there.
Three more locations.
OK.
So yeah, definitely
expanding that way.
We are celebrating our fifth
anniversary party in January,
and featuring like 7,
8, 30, 40, 50 beers.
I can't even keep track.
But we're having a
massive, massive event.
And we actually sold tickets
to our anniversary party
yesterday online.
And I'm not even kidding you.
We sold 600 tickets
in under one minute.
And the tickets were not cheap.
Thank you.
MIKE ARQUINES: How
much were there?
How much were they?
JELYNN MALONE: They
were $187 a ticket.
Anyway, it's insane.
But it's just a lot of
that collaboration energy.
We are featuring a ton
of beers that we've
done over the last year.
So a lot of craft
beer people are
coming from all over the place.
And they camped out in front
of our shop on Friday night.
We did like a small in-store
sale in our shop on Saturday
morning.
And I drove by at 9:30 the night
before, and there were people.
They were like, oh, I
drove in from Arizona
to buy a ticket to your
anniversary party in January.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: They
were camping out there.
JELYNN MALONE: What's that?
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: They
were camping out there
at 9:00 PM on a Friday night.
JELYNN MALONE: So
anyway, so we just--
expanding is definitely
number one right
now, which is to do that.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Our hope is
20 stores in the next 10 years,
is what we would love to do.
So that's our goal.
JELYNN MALONE: And as Mike
was mentioning cold brew,
like we were known as
a cold brew company.
People knew because we infused--
we do sell like regular
single origin cold brew,
but we also do a lot
of innovative stuff
where we infuse our
cold brews with all
these different flavors.
We'll do stuff that
tastes like vanilla.
We'll do stuff that tastes
like vanilla and strawberry,
chocolate-covered strawberries,
Ferrero Rocher flavored.
I mean, it's just
all over the place.
And so I think something
that would take things
to the next level is to
actually can our cold brews
and make them accessible
to just people
nationally, because I can't even
tell you how many emails we get
from people on the
East Coast like,
we want some of your cold brew.
And we're like, uh,
we don't ship that.
But definitely expanding our
cold brew line is a big one.
Continuing our efforts
in the Philippines
to just bring that
Philippine bean here
and to grow the market for it,
so roasters all over the world
start sourcing coffee from
the Philippines as well.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Just building
our coffee program even more,
and our direct trade
relationships even more.
JELYNN MALONE: And then as Mike
said, we do barrel-aged coffee,
so just really expanding on
the barrel-aged coffee program,
which is just us continuing
to push the envelope
and be innovative with
everything that we do.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG:
So a lot of things.
JELYNN MALONE: Oh,
Sam has something.
SAM MAGTANONG: And then just, I
think, lastly, for four years,
it was us.
We did everything, and we had
the opportunity to expand.
We've got 25 employees
now on payroll.
I've got four children.
We're trying to create a
sustainable business that
feeds families, and is able to
support a sustainable career.
So we'll keep working hard, and
keep staying true to our story.
And if you all are
in Carmel Mountain
Ranch in Rancho Bernardo,
please come by and say hi to us.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG:
Stop by, yeah.
MIKE ARQUINES: Yeah.
JELYNN MALONE: So after this
talk and you head outside,
we actually have a bunch of
coffee samples for you guys
to try.
We have-- do you know which
ones that they brewed today?
MIKE ARQUINES: We have
the Ethiopia hambela,
which is a natural
press process coffee.
And then we have a yirgacheffe,
which is a wash process.
So it's going to be interesting.
We wanted to bring two
different Ethiopians,
but different processes
so you could kind of
see the differences in those.
JELYNN MALONE: Do you guys
know what processing means?
I thought Bev was going
to talk about that.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG:
So processing is
what happens after the cherry
gets picked from the tree.
So there's natural
processing, which
is when they actually sometimes
leave the cherry on the seed.
And a lot of times
what can happen
is that the cherry
or this coffee
will retain a
berry flavor to it.
And then there's also washed,
where they take-- they depulp
the cherry off of the seed.
It goes through fermentation
and drying and all of that,
and then you'll get more
of what Mike was saying,
a lot of lemony flavors,
a lot of tart flavors.
So you're going to
be able to taste
those differences
between this Ethiopia
hambela and an
Ethiopia yirgacheffe,
because the hambela is a
natural process coffee,
and the yirgacheffe is a
washed processed coffee.
JELYNN MALONE: How
about the other coffees?
We have one Brazilian today.
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Yeah, we
have One-Brazilian Coconut.
It's a cold brew.
And then we've got some beer.
JELYNN MALONE: And we actually
have a short roasting demo
right outside when
you guys walk out.
So we actually brought
our one-pound roaster.
And you can actually
see the green beans.
If you've never
seen green beans,
it's right there for
you to see as well.
So is that it, guys?
Yeah?
BEVERLY MAGTANONG: Yeah.
I think so.
JELYNN MALONE: Thank you so
much for having us, you guys.